hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's help-wanted oh how you doing
over there oh yeah so this time I have
earbuds and that's gonna help me because
I don't have to wear the big bulky
headphones that I had before but it
won't help you because yeah what I was
saying the earbuds you know they they
they don't help me sound any better I
still sound like a bag of ass but you
know they'll help me hear better so I'll
know when Freddie's crawl not my
butthole
so that's good I guess I'm gonna go into
five nights at Freddy's 2 because I just
want to see toy chica there here we go
we're going right into it
no time to waste this time wrap grab and
release with trigger survive until 6
a.m.
seems easy peasy alright let's go for it
hey wait oh god dammit god dammit god
dammit
oh no no thank you god damn it I have to
do this again okay set floor level
alright okay hey buddy you know what you
can just come kill me you guys didn't
see anything that happened it was a
nightmare I can't explain how much of a
nightmare because it would take too long
I am gonna play this game and I'm even
but scared off of me and that's all
there is to it okay here we go thank you
wink wait five nights at Freddy's 2
boink boink as' I'm still ready I'm
ready for Freddy hello
[Music]
[Applause]
we hold on wait wait wait I have many
questions um wait I better watch I
remember how to play this one ah
Frick Oh Oh I need to do that
I hear noises in the door okay wait a
minute oh no oh no are you down there
oh okay put it down
why look one I can multitask because I'm
real smart okay
holy freaking okay they're back at
the base and that's almost time if you
relax oh my god
I don't like not having doors doors I
didn't like it before I want to be very
specific I didn't like not having doors
when I first played this game I
definitely don't like not having doors
right right about now please there's
like no feedback on when the light
actually hits or not okay are you guys
where are they oh you
okay Oh God
okay that was the first night I didn't
find a coin so I don't even know if that
was going to have their husband
preoccupied with stuffing things oh it's
beautiful
can I eat it what do I do with it what
do I come back here oh right on your
stoop boom crane the back of the nod
wink Oh guess who's only got no eyes boo
me I'll take this with me
I think nope never mind okay I didn't
even
oh hi you're still there well that
doesn't matter okay um okay yeah
yeah I know okay alright let me just
make sure everything's good for some
reason get going I'll I like I like I
like I like I like this this is no wait
no hang on oh no no no go back how do I
go back no this is wrong there's no way
to go back you can't go back
no no I have to die okay
why okay
[Music]
oh stop wait who's there Oh time people
oh my god okay well I got shot
just shut shut just shut your trap I'm
just gonna move on you shut up
everything's fine I just gotta do what I
gotta do to survive and that's not a lot
but I'm gonna do it you hear me where's
the coin I know there's gotta be like
Jesus okay all right we're on our own
now oh that's a lot of noise happening
right now why is a lot of noise
happening right now I don't know why I
love it always happening right now I
don't know why any noises having a
shutout Scott shut up oh my god why why
why why why
[Music]
okay good eye good eye sweet sweetums
along you know thank you for you know
is that about
that was normal that was a whole lot
normal um no look normal normal
everything is normal just normal that's
all this is normal this is definitely
[Music]
okay
hello so normal that wasn't the most
normal thing I've ever heard
[Music]
oh are you okay you know what hello
that's good right there okay goodbye
hey welcome to the party hey how are you
doing good to have you here
thanks so much for being here love you
big Li can you please go away oh my god
[Music]
okay basically it was pretty good okay
oh my god I hate it oh my god
don't weak I hate you uh what's wrong
with you oh my god okay well I've got
you now I guess that's good okay I guess
I'll just go in the night until I die
I just sack up
I should be fine it should be absolutely
interesting
what food is good it by I went got my no
no oh wait put it what what
happened whatever the hoop something
happened and I don't know what okay all
right is that the problem that I need to
worry about because this that you
I'm not that worried about you but I'm a
little worried about you because you
kind of like her right there in the way
of everything and that's okay when you
start moving I'll be I'll be ready I'm
ready like Freddie that's what you say
ready Freddie be the ready man Freddie
Freddie Freddie the ready man Freddie
ready boy ready ready ready Freddie
that's what they call you as who you are
to me yeah that's where to God I swear
to god I'm gonna kill nobody
I love peace and happiness
I have friends and I love my friends
that I have
we're alive like me that's something
that me and my friends have in common we
are all alive so let's keep it that way
why don't we yeah yeah I think so that's
good idea me do you all do this but I
mean are you guys just gonna hold it oh
that's not working okay that's not
working oh I guess I just got to eat
this remember how to deal with it okay
um I guess that was it you just kind of
hold it enough see hi welcome to the
party again table for one
mister fredbear why don't you go back to
playing that video game that you love
someone don't even think about me no
we're thinking about hey buddy listen
the night's almost over and I'm about to
win because I'm a badass and a hard-ass
rolled into one
I'm one bad hard-ass and you're just a
big sack of flabby nothing so how why
don't you just go a little day oh you do
that that'd be nice hmm
[Music]
someone was it hi hey you want to get
flashed good gracious me you look like
you
[Music]
[Applause]
I got mixed nuts
allergy-friendly this gray no coins just
a old toy chica Henry we went to great
lengths to create an authentic VR
experience including using scanned
photographs for reference and using
original performance routines where
applicable Oh using original performance
routines like you mean how they ever
originally programmed is that what
you're saying that's that's that's great
don't ya only got one night left that Y
is all red I don't like this red I don't
like the red let's give it a try see
what happens if I die well nothing else
will be expected nothing else that's
ever expected out of me so that's is
preferable shut up
you know I've just shut up just shut up
oh my god oh my god I can't I'm clear oh
[Music]
okay oh me pull up hi are you there
oh my god Oh
oh my god okay okay I have not been good
to you guys with my nature
[Music]
no I don't know I don't know I don't
know okay this just takes a steady hand
ooh stingy see Oh give me hug give me
kiss
give me food okay love you bye bye love
you bye bye
Wow I love you bye
[Music]
nobody
I feel all that today not to do my
friends alright today's the day that I
win today's the day that I win because I
am the king round here nobody will take
my crown not today no tomorrow and not
on a Tuesday especially nothing so come
on time when I finished my stupid bits
that I do yours up finish the
goddamn day please pretty please with
sugar on top
lumpy Lumpkins I'll kiss you okay
alright I am NOT proud of everything
that I said or declared in that moment
but I am proud that I beated and that's
all that really matters in the long run
I got lemon chica
[Music]
oh boy are you there hey you want this
don't forget throw this out uh nope you
didn't like that did you I'll come get
you someday okay so that is um that's
all of Fernet
all right so um hi hello how are you
okay I guess that's all for this episode
of five nights at Freddy's Help Wanted
I'm gonna get my ass out of here before
they kill me so thank you everybody so
much for watching a little more on this
soon they seem to be surrounding me
right now I'm just leaving a voicemail
for the next security guard who's gonna
tell my take my place so um so thank you
everybody and yeah I don't know why they
were looking at me like that but anyway
thanks everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]